Hunter Biden getting slapped in the face
again after the implosion of his
sweetheart plea deal the first son
thought he'd be popping the champagne
with his bong ripping sugar brother
lawyer over how they conned a judge into
giving the first son immunity from
future crimes but then the judge
torpedoed the whole thing and just hours
ago it looks like Hunter ain't getting
bailed out by pops is there any
possibility that the president would end
up pardoning his son no
I just said no I just answered
Hunter's crack team of lawyers are said
to be fuming at the judge for daring to
question the original plea deal
personally attacking her for being
appointed by Trump and even comparing
the judge to lancito remember the guy
from the O.J Simpson murder trial
the fact swirling around Hunter are
pretty damning so naturally the liberal
media is working overtime to cover for
the first song
they're weaponizing Joe Biden's son
against him it is only going to add more
fuel to the political fire that
Republicans were stoking on Capitol Hill
as they move forward with a potential
impeachment charger that's the goal of
what they want to do they want to muddy
up Joe Biden in the minds of Voters
ahead of the reelection they are going
to try to indict a father for loving his
son who has been addicted to drugs and
or alcohol and without evidence of the
father doing anything other than loving
that son and get a load of this as
Republicans mull impeaching Joe Biden
Adam Schiff says you can't do it without
evidence now how crazy could that be
the Republican
or to teach someone anyone no matter
whether there's any evidence just shows
how they have
descended into chaos
okay I'm going to start with you Jessica
oh oh that's an interesting angle I know
I'm going to try it
if this does move into an impeachment
inquiry and all of this evidence that I
so eloquently have present presented the
American people for all these years
finally comes out yeah in a full hearing
what will the Democrats defense be
because right now it's hear no evil see
no evil I don't think that that's true
and we talked about it
I was here Tuesday I guess and I said if
if he did something really wrong then
lock him up that's how this works I'm
not afraid of an impeachment inquiry
though you should be honest about the
fact that you're not going to get one
you have all of these Republicans that
have been on TV talking about Ken Buck
says it's it's theater or the shiny
object Tony Gonzalez says people at home
are concerned about real things Mike
Lawler Richard Hudson saying no one is
seriously considering this except Kevin
McCarthy who wants to go on TV all the
time and pretend as if it's happening so
it's not happening and I know that
that's sad for you and I hate to burst
your bubble about it I'm still bubbling
okay you you bubble as long as you want
but I'm just telling you
I wouldn't try to stop you
um but I'm not afraid of it and I think
that this would actually be a day of
celebration for people who think that
the system is rigged and we have these
two the two-tier system of justice
because Hunter Biden didn't get the
quote sweetheart deal and I was watching
Stephanie rule last night she had on
Joyce Vance who was a U.S attorney
and she said that the judge asked all
the right questions
that this was a completely appropriate
response to it and that there were
things in the deal that hadn't been made
public yet so I I I'm not seeing the
outrage about it yes judge smell the rat
that the doj was in cahoots with
Hunter's legal team and then blew the
thing up it'll be interesting when so
David Weiss the U.S attorney that
handled this case wants to set the
record straight because there are a lot
of people seems like lying about what
happened there so he'll be testifying
before the oversight committee get your
popcorn ready I assume that he's going
to defend the deal and how all of this
was handled
um but I'm I'm not concerned and I think
you know it's great that the White House
just said absolutely no pardon okay
we'll see if that holds judge Janine
we know today a lot that we didn't know
yesterday and we knew it was a con we
knew that there was favoritism but what
we didn't know yesterday was what we
found out today in the plea agreement
and the plea agreement makes it clear
that that plea That was supposed to go
down yesterday was not for anything in
perpetuity as Biden's lawyers suggested
and lied to the court because I have
before me the very transcript as well as
the plea agreement which says this does
not cover anything going forward and it
does not provide protection against
prosecution for any future conduct so
Biden's attorneys lied to the court and
when they realized that wasn't on the
table they were like we're not going to
do this okay it was in writing everybody
knew it and the court knew it but that's
not the end of it because this is the
same attorneys that the judge was able
to go back back and find out who called
the court clerk and said take the
Whistleblower testimony out of the
transcript all right and in addition to
that what's new today that we didn't
know yesterday is that the plan was that
after the defendant served probation on
two misdemeanor tax convictions that
those convictions were going to be
erased
erased are you kidding me it's unheard
of and let me tell you something else
about how corrupt the doj is you can say
two years probation on a misdemeanor
conviction but the probation officer can
say you're good now I'm taking you off
probation after six months you don't
need my permission to do that and let me
just respond to Adam
shiftless because I have to I can't say
it this is a guy who believes you have
to have evidence they indicted Trump on
a call where he said I want to know what
happened in Ukraine with Joe Biden
the right establishes that Joe Biden's
son and John Kerry's son-in-law were on
a board of a company in Ukraine where
they're in making 83 000 a month and for
which Hunter didn't report or pay taxes
on that eighty three thousand dollars a
month and in addition to that Joe Biden
goes over and says I have a million of
the a billion dollars of American
taxpayers money and I'm not giving it to
you Ukraine unless you get rid of the
prosecutor shokun who is investigating
the company that my son is on if that
ain't evidence and whatever his name is
the opposite of that Victor shulkin was
fired for not doing the investigation
into barisma it's the exact opposite
you're right about that I'm not he's
investigating was investigating Barista
and Joe Biden admitted by his own voice
in January of 2018
he said the bottom line is I told them
you don't get the prosecutor off the
case
now you're going first all the time Greg
Gutfeld well he thought that he had a
vaccine right that's what this was and
instead he it was like a Chinese crack
pipe it just fell apart yo it is amazing
to watch all of these women Swoon over a
reckless misogynist this guy does more
harm to women than Tick-Tock and
syphilis and in Hunter's world the usual
sweetheart plea is please put on five
condoms but
it's entertaining to see these how how
these women excuse with Hunter
everything they condemned with Trump so
I want I came up with a new game show
it's called what's worse uh or what
about ISM with Greg Gutfeld I love this
so number one what's worse paying for
sex with a porn star or subsidizing a
sizable portion of the sex trafficking
industry what's worse saying grab them
by the p word privately on a bus or
throwing around the n-word like it's a
pronoun for blacks on your phone when
you're buying drugs what's worse talking
about how hot your daughter is or
denying she actually exists oh what's
worse saying you want to build a wall or
trying to frame brown skinned people as
illegals for when you when you leave
your gun in a garbage can remember he
told the police I think they're illegals
finally what's worse having a crazy
relative named Mary say you're just a
big meanie or immediately banging your
brother's widow and compounding her
grief with addiction and perversity I
find myself increasingly jealous of
Hunter to do such horrible things and
have so many people in the media defend
him you know as America's bad boy it
defeats the purpose what's the risk of
being bad if everybody ignores it I
think we should play that game every
show I think it's an actual show it's
Fox Nation hosted by Greg Gutfeld but
you have to pay me for it
then that's a no
Sandra my response to Jessica saying
she's not worried is I would ask are you
worried about some of the things that
the judge said in that room which as we
go through that it's remarkable what she
was asking in that room she first
started out by saying some of the
provisions in this are not standard
they're different from what I normally
see only to go on to the doj prosecutor
standing there and ask have you ever
seen anything like this the response was
no ma'am you've had this entire
sweetheart plea deal fall apart before
the American public growing calls
whether you agree this is happening or
not from the GOP for an impeachment
inquiry I'm covering the White House
Press briefing during America reports
today and you don't even have a press
asking Kareen Jean-Pierre about it it is
unbelievable the media treatment of both
of these stories I will finish with this
that this there still could be a plea
deal and I think it's important to
acknowledge that we're going to watch
this play out for the next month or so
oh and they could certainly work things
out I think that needs to be said this
could still happen yeah it'll probably
still happen and it's going to be even
more corrupt in the first one can I just
died really quickly are you worried I'm
I'm not worried I thought it was really
interesting we'll see what David Weiss
has to say about it when he goes before
the oversight committee to the game and
a lot of that is bad on both sides there
but hunter Biden isn't running for
president and he isn't the president
well Joe Biden definitely didn't use the
n-word in text messages
[Music]
I wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now